it is kind of interesting the way his
branding i mean
it's still more or less the same but how
it started
because it how it started he was like
heavy on guns
like that was the [ __ ] yeah was guns
yeah
and then it like became the girls and
stuff and yeah him going to vegas and
[ __ ] i for sure thought when we went
over there we're just going to walk
around and there's just going to be like
fortnite crates everywhere like it was
just going to be
you know big ass guns just all over the
place oh yeah we didn't see a single gun
yeah by the way
for those who don't know we've been to
his house yeah in l.a [ __ ] huge
and it's huge we need to check in with
the security team we had to leave our
phones right yeah
yeah we had to check our phones in with
the with the head security guy who
is in an office right by the front door
and then he was like
we're like where do we go and he was
like just go past the bowling alley
to the to the to the elevator and take
the elevator up to like the fourth floor
it's like it's like our resort where are
we yeah it's like walking into a dave
and busters it's [ __ ] ridiculous
so yeah all the games are on level two
there's um fun slushies on level three
bro i'm sorry look at him without a
beard
he just looks like puff ass adam sandler
he's nothing without that beard that
beard is his power
[Laughter]
look at the dude's t-shirt on the right
that's hard
bro i'm dying oh my god dude i'm
dying it's [ __ ]
he's not the same guy without that beard
he needs to delete this picture
go one to the right see him with that
gun look at this
he is not the same guy holy [ __ ] he just
looks like a facebook dude
he is not the same okay alligator
murderer that one
sick bro he is oh my god
this [ __ ] came out of nowhere oh man
he's a
oh what is he in this full zebra outfit
damn dan you changed look at you used to
wear [ __ ] nylon zebra print
now look at you he used to be one of the
boys he used to be one of the boys man
he used to spray particles on us like
the rest of us
now exactly exactly too [ __ ] cool
man old old i missed the old danny b
don't you wish danny b
would go back to the nylon z to the wait
wait
go to the lake surfing one
oh never mind you go to the nylon zebra
print days
you know that was perfect for driving
around your town
sipping on a tall can from the tilted
kilt
yeah that i i do want to shout out i
want to shout out nick from patreon
yeah he commented he said man noel and
cody need to go back to that sugar gay
era of making dark and hilarious jokes
era of the podcast made for driving
around
l.a eating candy chicken you know
candy i want to show you out for that
because that's a great comment candy
chicken wasn't even that far away
man look at our boy look at long face
over here
yeah dude i'm screen capping all these
why dude this is a dope ass reply pick
right here
[ __ ] it is
just up to the wrist you don't even need
the six-pack in it
yeah this one right here
look at our boy what's he doing i don't
know he's not the same though
yeah i don't know gambling he used to
just be a vegas boy
yeah that's all he was yeah this is
vegas dave
dave bilzerian [ __ ] vegas dave
imagine if that was his name instead
like dude it's so funny because whoever
helped him in the beginning definitely
nailed his branding because if it was
even one step off he would not be this
big
yeah look at this he doesn't know what
he's doing look at this poor people make
love rich people [ __ ] this is horrible
oh my god that that's from that's right
from the boardwalk that's from t-shirt
ville on the boardwalk yeah and then
caption my lunatic friend had this shirt
made
oh look at this zany shirt we made
i kind of want that shirt yeah now you
do oh good
this is this is the next one merch
could you imagine bro we need all the
one percenters
one percent we're gonna buy you these
t-shirts and
and sponsor them so that you wear them
bro look at my dude what does it say
squad
uh sold something euro tour
my dude selfies with the blunt tbt
look at my guy yeah posted [ __ ] snack
time baby
we're just cruising danny bill's
instagram bro this is this is a [ __ ]
trip honestly this is so
interesting dude these pictures where he
has the models in the early days
just him with his hand around their
waist that's just so like scottsdale
it's just every picture in scottsdale is
this
what's hilarious dude is someone at some
point told him to stop smiling
yeah he just he no longer smiles in
pictures
no he got veneers now he smiles again oh
does he okay
yep all right yep yep okay let's let's
let's go modern danny bills
yeah you stop oh i just saw you on there
that was weird oh yeah
yeah i'm the only one bro i'm the only
one
what what year 2014 i'm like
that was weird hold up what when is this
2015. yeah i'm the only one man it's a
trip
yep there it is look at me look at me in
the six
look at me in the tic-tac-toe board
right here man that's hilarious
i'm honored that he would put me between
a pic of a helicopter and his foot
highly highly coveted
pieces of [ __ ] whatever it's
hilarious man
anyway oh so good danny bills
anyways yeah we've talked about him now
for like 20 minutes but
did we really talk about danny bills
that long yeah but it's funny
yeah we've been to his house dude we met
him remember
vegas dave what am i doing way back is
dave
we walked up and we said hey what's up
and he just he didn't even give us the
time of day at all nah
nah he like at all
no he uh we came in and he was just
posted with
some girls and then um at some point he
like left his [ __ ] his um his chad
throne
and he came down and he looked at us and
he goes
yeah you guys can stay you hang out up
here if you want
bathrooms are downstairs
and then if it is [ __ ] he brought
over that bong and him and like
five girls were just taking these huge
bong rips and i was like it's about to
get messy dude
and then odell beckham jr came yeah
did a shot with us and then he left
that was we i'm not i'm not not making
this up also this is all real
it was a weird weird weird night night
and this was uh the the weirdest [ __ ]
was
i don't even know why i did it like this
but it was either
post or dan
bilzerian was like this is odell and i
went oh i know
and then odell went oh what's up bro
you're from the millionaire vine yeah
[Laughter]
i follow dan b you're from the
millionaires i was just thinking bro
could you imagine if i [ __ ] did that
[ __ ] oh my god
did what yo dude you probably don't
remember this
um oh you walked up to dan
you know man i don't want to make you
weird but
you know g'day good to meet you do you
no you don't do you know
yeah yeah you say the tagline he's like
what
who is this [ __ ] i don't i'm sorry why
are you saying that to me no come on
who is this [ __ ]
fist over the face uh do you see it do
you see it
i brought the hat i brought the hat in
case you forgot
just in my backpack security made me
check it in
you